was ganz brisant ist an der Situation
der ukraine-konflikt kommt diesen
Terroristen zu Nutze denn über die
Ukraine kommen viele Menschen
überfordert asienbereich Tadschikistan
kirgisin und ähnliches und da gibt es
eine neue Gruppierung die nennt sich
islamischer Staat in der Provinz Provinz
Cora San und das sind sehr sehr
brandgefährliche Menschen und was macht
Frau Faser sie schwächt jetzt die
Bundespolizei mit der Novellierung des
bundespolizeigesetzes und sagt
Polizisten an der Grenze wenn da
Menschen kommen die
Migrationshintergrund haben migrantisch
aussehen dann dürfte die eigentlich
nicht kontrollieren das ist racial
Profiling außer ihr stellt eine
kontrollquittung aus dass die Menschen
sich hinter beschweren können dass sie
kontrolliert wurden und das macht
natürlich in so einer Situation die
Sache nicht besser